today we're going to be speaking with Frank
von Hippel, who is a professor at Northern
Arizona University and author of the book
The Chemical Age How Chemists Fought Famine
and Disease, Killed Millions and Changed Our
Relationship with the Earth.
And Frank, you know, in reading about the
history of chemistry and chemists, it seems
that a theme with with essentially every technological
advancement in human history, agriculture
comes to mind, nuclear power comes to mind.
We both have much good and the possibility
of much bad that I am I am I correctly understanding
that that is essentially the broad history
of chemistry?
Yes, for sure.
And like you're saying, it's also the history
with physics and many other fields that lead
to technological advances, that we have these
wonderful innovations, but they have massive
unintended consequences.
I think a lot of times when people think about
chemistry, they think about the last hundred
years, 150 years, maybe two hundred years,
and they think of chemicals that include things
like pesticides as an example or chemistry
used in medical technologies.
But the history of chemistry really goes back
much further than that.
It does.
It really goes back to alchemy in a way where
people were using trial and error to find
new ways of doing things often impossible,
things like trying to turn lead into gold.
But those experiments led to a lot of advancements.
And I would say that modern chemistry really
arose in the early eighteen hundreds with
the advent of organic chemistry as chemists
learned how to synthesize different kinds
of chemicals that are only otherwise found
in nature.
And that's what gave rise to our modern pesticides,
our modern chemical weapons and so on.
It seems that correct me if I'm wrong, but
there's a bit of an analogous history with
what what we now know of as two very different
fields, astronomy and astrology.
At one point there was an overlap between
those and then they eventually sort of separated
and much the same way.
Alchemy, which now is the subject of many
sort of pseudo science books and and sometimes
overlaps with everything from psychics and
other things.
At one point it was right there at the start
of modern chemistry as well.
That's exactly right.
And so with the advent of modern science where
we disprove things and we subject ideas to
experimentation, of course alchemy went away
and we have the the modern field of chemistry
rise out of that.
When we start to think back in the history
of chemistry and thinking about the major
breakthroughs within the field, what are sort
of like the top level, most important milestones?
Well, I would say the first one would be the
synthesis of urea by Frederic Vogeler in eighteen
twenty eight.
And that's really the the point of origin
of organic chemistry.
But there are many others after that.
And in terms of the history of pesticides,
we have the first commercial pesticide which
was called Bordeaux mixture as a copper sulfate
solution in the eighteen seventies, and that
then led to the proliferation of initially
toxic metal based pesticides.
And then we had major inflection points in
World War One and World War two, World War
One, because it was incredible cross-fertilization
of talent of chemists who were working both
on pesticides and chemical weapons.
So we had pesticides become a chemical weapons
and we had chemical weapons become pesticides.
And by the end of World War One, a quarter
of the artillery shells flying over the trenches
had chemical weapons in them, which is extraordinary
to think about.
Now, just that was really a chemical war.
It was the chemists who who really decided
the outcome of that war.
And then things got even more advanced and
and horrific in a way, with World War Two,
where we got the advent of the organophosphate
nerve gases like sarin and tavan, which were
developed by Nazi scientists and those developed
into the modern organophosphate insecticides
after the war.
So early on in the history of pesticides.
I mean, my reading of it seems to suggest
that this was really seen as just a boon and
a great thing, all positives in the pros column
and really nothing in the cons because it
allowed more food to get to the point at which
it could provide sustenance to people and
it provided an expansion of available calories
and really solved a lot of problems that were
that were prevalent at the time.
Was it that were there people sounding alarms
early on and sort of like what is the history
of when the other side of pesticides started
to become more known?
Yeah, it's a terrific question because initially
chemists who were developing these chemicals
were fighting the scourges of humanity that
have faced us since we started agriculture.
They were fighting famine and they were fighting
infectious diseases.
So famine, because crops are destroyed by
pests like rats and cockroaches and grasshoppers
and so on, but also crops are destroyed by
plant pathogens.
And that's what led to the potato blight disaster
that caused the greatest famine ever recorded
in Ireland in the 1840.
So chemists were trying to fight famine and
they were also trying to fight infectious
diseases that were vectored by animals like
malaria and yellow fever, typhus, bubonic
plague and so on.
And so the motivations were really good and
these chemicals were quite effective.
They were averting famine and averting diseases.
But the first alarms really started, I would
say, right after World War One.
There were a lot of people getting poisoned
by toxic metals in their food, especially
lead and arsenic, which were used in insecticides
and often present on produce.
And if people didn't wash the produce, they
could get poisoned from it.
But even then, it was kind of a grumbling.
And then after World War Two, there was further
grumbling as people saw widespread loss of
wildlife.
It really wasn't until 1962 when Rachel Carson
Popish Silent Spring that we saw massive public
outrage about the pollution and the destruction
of the environment caused by these chemicals,
as well as human health effects when it comes
to there's now sort of a new sort of newer
movement of earth friendly.
And again, it's this idea of of so-called
pesticides, but they're sort of like non chemical
or friendly things.
I'm not actually I'm not actually aware of
what the substances are.
But you'll sometimes hear, hey, you know,
you can use you spray lavender on your garden.
This is not a real example, but you put lavender
on your garden and then put onion peels and
then the animals just don't come near.
Is is there what is the chemistry community
think about that type of thing?
Can something totally innocuous really be
as effective as some of these more pernicious
chemical pesticides, or is that in order to
get the huge benefit, you've got the huge
risk as well?
Yeah, so it's a great question.
And unfortunately, with the big benefit of
using chemical pesticides, we also create
our own dependency on them because these chemicals
not only kill the pests, they kill the predators
and parasites of those pests.
So they kill the spiders that eat those pests.
They kill the the parasitic dwarfs that in
fact, those pests, they kill the birds that
eat those pests.
And then you end up in this vicious cycle
where you have to use more and more chemicals
to get the same yield.
So it's not a simple answer and.
And really, there are many organic solutions
that don't require chemical pesticides that
are quite effective, but part of it has to
do with the way crops are rotated, grow in
a diversity of crops rather than a monoculture.
If you have ten thousand acres of the same
crop, of course, you're going to get an outbreak
of pests because it's this giant salad bowl
for them.
So we need to be thinking holistically about
how we grow our food and at the same time
reserve chemicals for when we really need
them.
In my opinion, that would be for fighting
infectious diseases where we we have outbreaks
of pests that we need to handle.
Yeah, I found absolutely fascinating Omnivore's
Dilemma by by Michael Pollan, where he talks
about going to Joel Salatin farm and I believe
it's Virginia and explains how there's this
kind of vicious cycle of, you know, you start
to need, for example, antibiotics for cows
when the cows are being fed grain instead
of grass, because that's not natural for the
digestive system of the cow.
And it at least makes the case that at some
level you can have this regenerative agriculture.
That doesn't depend on the types of pesticides
that that you write about in the book.
Can that can that really work at scale?
Yeah, so I think it's a great question that
we need to explore as a society, because it
hasn't really been tried.
We went from operating a small farms throughout
the world to having industrialized agriculture
after World War Two.
Population has grown tremendously.
And now we need to see can we do a sustainably?
We have to find a way to do sustainably because
it's certainly not sustainable the way that
we rely on chemicals now and the damage it
does to our health and the environment.
So there's going to be some kind of a compromise
where we're using the minimum of these pesticides
that that one needs to use while maximizing
all of these other benefits of using diverse
agriculture and and and going to a smaller
scale, more local markets.
Why are we shipping foods all around the world
that can be grown nearby?
So we need to completely rethink our agriculture
up to go back a little bit to the sort of
public health side of of the field of chemistry.
What do you make generally?
I mean, I have more specific questions, but
what do you make generally about the types
of concerns expressed over the last few months
about the coming coronavirus vaccines, some
based on the speed with which the vaccines
were developed, some based more on conspiracy
theories about Bill Gates and microchips,
but concerns that at least some some seem
in good faith about the makeup of the vaccines
and the storage and the long term effect on
the body.
What's your general sense of the discussion
around vaccination right now?
Right.
So I'm a big advocate of vaccines and including
the new vaccines coming out for covid.
I think they're incredibly important.
And although the vaccine for covid-19 was
developed incredibly quickly over the last
10 months or so, the technology it's based
on has been in development for 20 years.
And so it's not it's a new technology to be
employed for a human vaccine, but it's been
in development for a long time and the biology
is well understood.
So to me, the vaccine looks very safe, it
looks efficacious.
It's more efficacious than many of us were
expecting.
And certainly I'll be asking my parents to
get it as soon as it's available for older
people and for the rest of us when it's available.
So and as far as the D the slander against
Bill Gates and people like him is just horrible.
Here you have someone who's working very hard
for the public benefit, using his own resources
to do so, and then he's getting attacked for
it.
I just find it absolutely horrifying that
that's going on.
One of the arguments that sometimes being
made and to call it an argument maybe is a
bit of a stretch.
But one of the claims that's being made is
that we don't know if by test, by testing
these vaccines for a few months on people
in phase three trials, we don't know if a
year, two, three, four years down the line,
there will be some unforeseen follow on effects.
Now, of course, it's a sort of indefeasible
argument in the sense that if a vaccine has
been around 50 years, you don't really know
that after fifty one, it doesn't cause some
new problems.
So you could always make this argument.
But in terms of what we know about vaccines,
what the only thing I've been able to find
about long term vaccine effects that go beyond
a few days is a vaccine, the exact one I forget
that doubled the risk of ironbar syndrome,
I think from one in two million to one in
one million over the life of the individual
up.
What can we say about, generally speaking,
at the chemical level, the idea that years
down the line a vaccine could cause something?
Sure.
And actually the example you gave is a good
one, because typically where vaccines have
an adverse effect is that the scale of one
in a million or two in a million people that
have some serious consequence of that.
And if you compare that to the serious consequence
of getting measles or getting mumps and rubella
or or tetanus or any of these other things
that we get vaccinated against, it's it's
there's no comparison.
So, yes, there may be one in a million, two
in a million people who, due to their genetic
makeup and their environment, have some serious
consequence of a new vaccine.
But look at the mortality rate of people from
covid-19.
And we have about one percent or almost one
percent of people infected are dying.
And that scale there's no comparison to one
in a million versus one in one hundred.
So in terms of vaccine history, I think that's
what the lesson is, is that nearly always
they proved to be safe.
There are cases where they're not safe, usually
discover that quite quickly.
And if this happened with a dengue fever vaccine,
for example, and so when those problems occur,
they're pulled off the market, the problem
is solved.
And we're very lucky to live in a time where
the science is so advanced that something
like this can't be developed this quickly
rather than suffering through 30 years of
covid-19 before we have a solution.
Very, very well said.
We've been speaking with Frank von Hippel,
who teaches at Northern Arizona University.
The book is The Chemical.
Age, how chemists fought famine and disease,
killed millions and changed our relationship
with the Earth.
A Frank, I so appreciate your time today.